I wanted to be able to have my avatar
manifest some of those feelings
that I was actually experiencing.
My name is Guillermo Bernal. I'm a graduate student
at the Media Lab at the Fluid Interfaces
Group. My research focus falls in the
back and forth between digital and
physical.
Looking into how physiological
information like brain signals
electrodermal activity and any type of
physiological sensor can be used to
allow us to express in the digital world
our needs that we have.
One thing that we did here is flexible pcbs that actually
begin to pick up physiological data from
EEG brain signals as well as like your
vocal cords and muscle explanations.
And then there are some fiber optics that
are in here and when you have some sort
of activity it has an LED and begins to
brighten and have different patterns
almost replicating how like neural
networks begin to fire different microvolts in our brains.
I think what inspires me is a mix of
the unknown and the excitement of something new.
How can we make a technology more accessible?
How do we actually provide the means to show
how we feel? And how we want to
express in these virtual reality applications?
This project couldn't
happen without the help and assistance
from the Council for the Arts at MIT and
the MIT Media Lab summer program for
Hacking Manufacturing.